i'm joined now by the health secretary
matt hancock mr hancock good morning to
you
good morning health secretary you must
be feeling a very happy and mightily
relieved to see this
come to fruition this morning i'm
feeling quite emotional actually
watching those
pictures it's been it's been such a
tough year for so many people
and um finally we have
we have our our way through it our um
our
light at the end of the tunnel as so
many people are saying and just watching
margaret that you know it seems so
simple having a
a jab in your arm but that will protect
margaret
and it'll protect the people around her
and if we manage to do that
in what is going to be one of the
biggest programs in nhs history
if we manage to do that for everybody
who's vulnerable to this disease then
we can uh that then we can we can move
on and we can
return to normal and i i'm just so
grateful to all of the team who've made
this happen
um the we were talking about mhra the
regulator not often regulators get
a big round of applause but i think the
country should be applauding them
and to of course the the vaccines task
force and kate bingham who
who spotted this vaccine and bought it
early
and then to the nhs family who are going
to make this happen you know
there's enormous amount of work still to
do
i think it's very important that we
stress that but i'm i'm really
really grateful to everybody who's who's
brought us to this moment
and what does this moment this morning
represent
it's been described as the beginning of
the end but where do you see
that end coming does this represent your
through this by spring thinking
well the first thing it represents is
the triumph of
science and human ingenuity
over what is a absolutely beastly
disease
and um i that is yeah i've always
believed that
through backing the science we would get
there
and today is a a big moment
in that in in scientific endeavor and
you know this can start
to to heal this this
disease right across the world and
protect people
everywhere through these these vaccines
and this being just the first one
in terms of what it means here in the uk
of course it's great news that we are
the first country in the world to have
this clinically authorized and
being able to roll out this program and
when enough people who are vulnerable
to covert 19 have been vaccinated
then of course we can lift the
restrictions it is very important to say
to everybody
what is that when do you anticipate that
that will be
health secretary well we think that will
be in the spring
it's very important to just for
everybody
uh watching that whilst we vaccinate
people
and we will do that at the pace at which
the
manufacturers can produce the vaccine
whilst we vaccinate people and once we
get that second dose in
we've got to hold our nerve we've got to
stick together and we've got to follow
the rules you know it's no good
everybody relaxing now we've got to
hold firm until the vaccination program
has reached enough vulnerable people
so that so that so that we you know we
don't have people dying from coronavirus
in the numbers that we do today which is
still much much too high
okay you mentioned that the pace of
manufacturing how many of the 800 000
doses from uh pfizer are
here now and when do you expect the next
consignment to be
coming in we were expecting a lot more
weren't we we have been told up to four
million by the end of the year
is that accurate well the the 800 000
are in the country
and uh well many are being many are in
hospitals across the uk
we've got uh up to 80 hospitals will be
delivering the
vaccine today and up to 70 sorry i
should say up to 70 hospitals
delivering the vaccine today of course
you know in one example the vaccine is
no longer in the hospital it's in
margaret's arm
which is uh which is wonderful and then
in terms of the future
we have several million that are agreed
with pfizer to be delivered
in the remainder of this month we're not
putting an exact figure on it
because that manufacturing pro process
is
itself difficult and we've got to make
sure that they're brought into the
country safely
but as they're brought into the country
and ready to deployed
be deployed then then the
the nhs will be there and ready to
make sure that people can get them to
help to make sure that
uh we we protect people from from the
disease
yeah i want to ask how confident you are
in that supply chain you've talked about
potential difficulties
in manufacturing because 800 000 doses
is 400 000 patients because the second
dose is being
held back for them does that suggest
that you're not expecting
enough to come in within the next three
weeks
well we've always expected the vast bulk
of the vaccination program to be in the
new year
and so for for people watching if you're
in your 80s
then the nhs will get in contact with
you
and invite you in to be vaccinated but
the vast majority of people
will be vaccinated in the new year not
this side of christmas
so that that's um yeah the reason i'm
asking i suppose is you you
you could have taken the decision to
vaccinate a full 800 000 patients
on the basis that you were expecting to
get the next
doses in within that time frame are you
saying that you're not expecting those
no i'm not i'm not saying that actually
uh the uh
we have a high degree of confidence in
the delivery that will come next week
which means that we are able to get uh
going on
the full number um but you know the
rollout will start
and it will start in those uh up to 70
hospitals that i mentioned across the uk
and then it will roll out and get uh get
broader
um you you were discussing in the
bulletins i i was listening to the need
to get
to care homes because obviously many
care home residents are both very
vulnerable
but also can't travel easily so we need
to make sure that we get to
care homes and we want to use
gps and pharmacists to be able to get
the vaccination sites closer to where
people live
so we start with the big hospitals which
is what we're doing today
make sure we get all of the processes
smooth and straight
and and get this off to a good start and
then we'll expand the number of
uh the the number of centers that we
have
to be able to reach people
okay and in terms of care homes because
care home residents are in that top
priority
bracket where are we in terms of getting
approval from the mrhra
to get batches into care homes so that
the vulnerable can be vaccinated
in situ yes so it's incredibly important
that
not only do we have the vaccine itself
approved
but also that the delivery of the
vaccine is safe
because it has to be kept at minus 70
famously
we've got to make sure that the process
of getting the vaccine
to the to the site is itself
safe and that's what the mhra have been
working with the nhs to
to make sure we have the protocols in
place for that and the reason that
that's taken a little bit longer
is that the the full characteristics of
this
vaccine were only known a couple of
weeks ago so they've worked at
incredible pace to get this into place
already
and we'll get that sorted in the next
couple of weeks so we uh we hope to be
vaccinating
before the end of the year i hope to be
vaccinating in
care homes before christmas and start
that program before christmas
but we will only do this as fast as
it is safe to go that's been our
principle all the way through
and um you know as you've seen from what
we've managed to achieve
so far the regulator working with the
nhs
can can it can do this swiftly
and in a smart and agile way but they're
doing it
in a way that is safe and so that's the
reason
we've just got to make sure that the
processes we have to get the vaccine
safely to the care homes is done in a
way that means that
it is um it is absolutely secure and i'm
sure people will understand
why it's worth taking the extra few days
to get that process
uh sorted whilst of course we can get on
with the
we can get started with the program in
in hospitals as as margaret's
demonstrating uh
with you in coventry
can we get clarification from you as
health secretary on the issue of
vaccine passports these are the vaccine
cards appointment cards or reminders
that people
will be given after they've had the
second dose
of the vaccine do they no longer need to
carry those or do they need
to maintain those keep them on their
person at all times
they don't need to carry those at all
they are standard nhs reminder cards
because you have to have the second dose
obviously so it's critical that we give
people an appointment
and that they can come back for that
second dose
so these cards are a standard nhs
reminder card for your follow-up
appointment for the second dose of the
vaccine which
is what gives you the immunity having
both of the doses
and you know we're not proposing to have
a a sort of immunity certificate that
allows you to do different things
what we want to do is get as many people
vaccinated
as quickly as we safely can and then
once we've protected
the the those who are vulnerable from
covid
then we can start to lift the
restrictions that we've got in place and
you know i want to lift those
restrictions as much as anybody does
but i only can possibly recommend that
when it is safe to do so um and it'll be
safe once we've vaccinated enough of the
people who are vulnerable to the disease
that's the plan and it will take some
uh months uh to get there but
what is absolutely critical is that in
the meantime
everybody follows the rules this is i i
can't overest
over i can't over emphasize this enough
that we are we are not there yet
you know we've taken a big step forward
but we're not there yet
and everybody still needs to follow the
rules because you know i think it would
just be
it would be terrible if we were to you
know see that we've now
got the solution it is it is coming it
is being delivered
um and if we um you know if we all
relax too much at this point
unfortunately
then the virus is still a deadly disease
until we've got enough people protected
from it so let's stick at it
as well as the logistical challenges of
rolling out the vaccine you've also got
challenges around disinformation
as health secretary what what do you say
to those who may be concerned
or skeptical about having the vaccine
well i i think that the best people to
speak on this
are the the clinicians themselves
and um those who are who spend their
lives and
are experts in vaccine development
um who will explain very clearly
that the a vaccine is so much better
than getting the disease
it is safe we would not have the
have allowed this moment that we're
seeing on our screens to happen
if it weren't safe and approved by the
regulator
which is the mhra which is which is
globally
uh respected for its uh judgments
um and um and critically
you know the clinicians in charge of
this like professor jonathan van tan
are recommending the vaccine not only
for um
for for others but also for members of
their own family
um when they're when it's appropriate so
you know listen to the trusted voices
listen to the clinicians
um and um it's it's clear that getting
the vaccine is good for you
and it's good for your family and
frankly it's good for the country
because we need to get enough people
vaccinated so that we can
then be able to lift the restrictions
i'm away from the vaccine now and
brexit the prime minister had a very
lengthy call yesterday afternoon
evening with ursula von de la
no progress made did an eu
ambush derail the talks
well uh obviously i haven't been
involved in the uh
in the day-to-day of these talks what i
can say is that
i know the prime minister is straining
every sinew
to try to get a deal that works for both
the uk
and the eu that deal is uh
potentially doable but the eu obviously
has to want to do it and uh he's
therefore prepared to travel to brussels
to really uh lean in to trying to get
that deal
but at the same time we're fully
prepared for whatever
outcome we've uh we're we're ready
uh to um to proceed without a further
agreement if that is what the eu uh
decides but we've got a
you know we've got to make sure that we
um
you know we negotiate hard and we put
everything into it and that's what the
prime minister is doing
health secretary matt hancock thank you
very much for joining us this morning
thank you good to be on